[Music]
so Europe's going through quite a bit of
a shift at the moment in terms of brexit
where as yours your work focused on this
at all or do you have ideas towards
what's currently - yes I mean I have
looked a lot of what is happening in
Europe and also with the current trench
- what's populism but specifically about
brexit having grown up in Denmark with
Great Britain as like the country of you
know of God species how we felt about
England having saved Europe twice in the
last century from fascism and also being
the country of all great pop music or
you know the big literature as a writer
you know from Shakespeare onwards it's
you look to England fantastic philosophy
is architecture music and so on and then
you get to this point where you see
what's happening right now with bricks
is that splitting the country totally
into politicians who seem more
interested just in the chair of they are
trying to hold on to right here now
rather than to try to make a vision for
the country where their inside/outside
leave you I so sad to watch but it it's
such a loss for Europe that Britain
won't be there I don't think even
economically because there will be some
kind of deals in anyway Europe is big
enough but but culturally also not to
talk about what course what I think will
be the cost for Britain in many
different ways but you can see that as
an outsider should not look so much um
but what really saddens me is that no
one has said listen there must be
another way to do this if in the
referendum we were almost half even if
it was a majority - what's breaks it but
it means you have to find a compromise
kind of solution so that everybody can
feel okay that represents what we were
saying in the referendum it wasn't one I
mean it wasn't all blacks it was a
middle kind of road thing that was
towards breaks it so the solutions
should reflect that but not on that in
Denmark in 92 when discussing the
Maastricht Treaty that became adopted at
that time works which became made Europe
going much more to what's a union and he
had
before the Danes actually said knowing
that referendum there was a big shock in
Europe at the time and we were then
allowed to renegotiate so that we got
four reservations to the Maastricht
Treaty we are not part for example of
the defence corporations of the police
security cooperation we are not part of
the Euro we're not we are part of
Schengen but in a special way and anyway
these four were we caught reservations
then make meant that when we had a
second vote on it it was a major
concerns of the Danes had been addressed
so people then could vote yes and I just
I mean can't understand why no one
neither in the EU or in Britain has said
let's look at what are the real concerns
of the British people where is the
situation for Great Britain different
than the rest of the countries in the
you because each country has some
specifics that is why concerns are
raised and it's clear enough that most
immigrant refugees always go to Britain
because English is an easy language to
learn we hear it all the time because
jar their jobs so it's fair enough that
maybe that's an area become where people
are more concerned that maybe Britain
should be allowed to have a little bit
of border control than the other
European countries and and some of the
other things that really people are
concerned about could be addressed and
make a special deal for Britain that
could allow Britain to be in the EU
under some special conditions and then
you could have a second vote on that I
mean that and I would believe any
visionary politician should go for
because I mean this is a future of this
country future of young people and also
the future of Europe in a certain way
it's like everybody is stuck in these
corner positions
it's either breaks it or nothing it's
not true politics you can discuss
everything you can make laws about
everything and I can't have an issue
like this divided the country it there
must be better solutions and that's why
I'm so passionate about it because even
you know speaking to driver drove me in
here this morning was a break sit here
and stop cornered off but when you open
the debate and say okay so what are your
real concerns could they be addressed
while still Britain is in the
and yes we had a discussion while at the
end of the day when you dropped me off
you said well maybe you'll actually
change this mind here but you have to
address people's concerns then there's a
possibility for Britain just stay in the
in Europe or even if Britain and leaves
believes on on terms that are so that is
to the benefit a best part
or you can sail you at least limit the
damage for everybody but this way of
going about it where it's just a clash
and people trying to you know run for
the power positions is so destructive
and you know someone who really loves
and I looked up to Great Britain my
whole life but I'm just so sad about it
do you think no I think a lot of the
division comes from
maybe it's possible to renegotiate a
relationship with the EU why we're still
in the EU but people's worry is that
there's been nobody wins because they
were in the eve we don't have control
over the laws of the EU the thing is the
EU is not like some natural catastrophe
that nobody can influence every member
of the EU influences the EU laws even my
own small country than mine we you know
can influence what happens and I think
it's very odd actually that Great
Britain has not carried quite its way in
the EU perhaps because there was so much
EU scepticism but we are many smaller
countries and here that I've just been
waiting for Britain to put more lead so
it's not some what's the German Franco
axis that decides much but but really
the big decisions in the EU all the laws
are adopted by all Member States
everyone have their say so it's
compromised laws it's not some countries
deciding or Britain or deciding over
Denver we are part of making those
decisions and the thing is when you stay
outside anyway the word is decided
elsewhere will influence so much what
happens your country no country is big
enough to be autonomous in the world
today I mean I would even think not
China though they might have a bigger
chance but you know not Britain not
Germany not any European country and the
thing that really has changed our lives
in the last 20 years or everywhere here
that's global capitalism that's the
freedom of capital movements that's the
fact that so much of what's going on in
the world economy the profit goes into
offshore accounts it's not part of the
whole welfare system what goes on in our
societies that's right hospitals lack
funding schools like funding roads like
funding and so on because where the real
money is made it never benefits though
other grander tax systems that we all
depend upon and then people turn against
Europe because they think oh this thing
is running out of hand we are you know
we have lower real income as we used to
and you know lower welfare
goods the education is falling apart and
so on and they think this is because of
decisions in Europe but it's the other
way around
I mean look who stands up to the global
multinationals and particularly the tech
companies for others that's you know the
Commissioner for competition in the EU
and it's only as a whole block that the
EU is strong enough to take them on no
individual country can do this
and even if Britain stands alone or it
would go for any other country standing
alone the first thing that she has to do
is to make new trade laws with every
country and the moment you make an
agreement with another country you give
off some of your sovereignty that's part
of any agreement so whether we call it
the EU or it's a number of specific
agreements the same thing will happen
and the whole you know world works on
and a system of international law in
order that we build up through many
generations and through the wars one
realized we need a Geneva Convention and
then later that we needed a United
Nations and lots of different specific
conventions on how to behave towards
each other that's why we have a human
rights declaration and so on and Britain
has been a heavyweight in developing a
lot of these so it's so sad to see
Britain I want to go off and step out of
there all these obligations that the
country used to spare head and of course
you know leaving the EU doesn't mean
they were draws from everything else but
I feel like when there's this talk about
all we want autonomy people don't
understand stepping out of the EU
doesn't give that autonomy and so what
would your message be for whoever is the
next Teresa may how how do we move on to
create what you want to see it is to to
really make her vision of how to bring
this country forward in a way that
speaks to the concerns of the people who
vote it breaks it and and yet also takes
into account that almost half the
country and particularly all younger
people voted to stay in which also meant
had that referendum taking place five or
ten years later probably
one because the younger generations
wanted to stay in so that has to play in
and it is possible I really believe to
say what are the actual concerns and
then go back to the EU and say okay if
we want to be able to give our
population a whole different choice they
have to have a choice where those the
concerns of the brexit ears are
addressed within the EU and then you you
give people and the other thing is to
say look at where the money for the
brexit campaigns and the people who are
the strong breaks the tears is a lot of
them have the offshore accounts and
millions are poured in to break it
because who really will benefit from
breaks it are the people who operate in
that financial black world or that world
of no control and what they don't want
is it the EU is trying to make the whole
financial system much more transparent
so it's not possible to hide this money
outside of the economy of everyone and
so that's why there are people with this
these humongous amounts of money who
have all the interest in brexit and they
then go and sell these arguments Falls
up in earth or false autonomy to people
who feel pressured but exactly because
of those offshore operations and if you
know I really would say the next Prime
Minister has to look at this has to dare
to take on the P the super-rich with
these offshore accounts and you know
people should look at who funds and if
you get a prime minister who then just
even speaks along these things also look
at who funds them and if that some
people will offshore accounts
you just know why they're going for
breaks it it's just to benefit
themselves it's not because of the
interest of the larger population and I
mean but hopefully you get a prime
minister who was willing to look uniting
the country again and really look at
what's best for the majority of the
population and not just the super-rich
who wants to hide them
it's really interesting as well that you
brought in the cultural connection which
is perhaps not being talked about as
much at the moment as the political
economic ramifications and practices and
those specific examples of literature
music that you grew up with that you
would see it be elastic I mean right you
know I grew of course with the
generation where I was yeah it was just
after Beatles but we still listen a lot
to bills you know it was Rolling Stones
it was a blonde years American yeah yeah
yeah
Supertramp is from here
well Donovan who was actually here at
the festival
I'm assist that yeah that whole cultural
thing I remember my first book that I
read in original language in English is
called go ask alice and it just opened
this whole world yeah of sort of
literature and and I say we just we
really grew up and I think it's probably
not understood in Britain how great the
cultural influence in Europe was and and
also how much we want Britain involved
also exactly for the role of Britain has
played in developing the international
institution and the view and human
rights and and we our whole generation I
grew up on a non-english call and of
course also it's the universe of Monty
Python I mean I don't think I know
anyone on the continent of might who
didn't see yeah Monty Python and all all
the other shows that came up from here
of course all the films also and don't
throw that away and I also think that
what hasn't been communicated enough and
this is where you really is at full is
our gratitude on the continent that
Britain safe destroyed from fascism in
the last century you've got all your
young men killed for our sake and yes
maybe it's set at the events political
island but it's person-to-person also I
think very important
because then it's again the EU is not
that far off the other thing it's
something very close to human relations
that we know your grandfather's got
killed for our freedoms and therefore
also I think it's the disaster of the
European politicians are not willing to
say we will accommodate some specific
conditions for Britain because she's
such a valued member of our community
and finally what role do you think I
think and that's individual I just saw
that there's a group of her British
authors that had made a big petition in
The Guardian signing that they will
encourage people to push for Romania's
in the European Parliament elections and
so on and maybe it has an influence and
I think it's good they do it but I'm
actually not sure they're really real
reach the people who wrote it
brexit I think talking to people high
and low everyone to see you hear the
concerns but also so you can explain
maybe there's another way to look at
things and also culturally and this is
where probably authors have something to
say to say how much they are influenced
by what comes from other countries no
country is an island in that sense where
I live in Denmark in Elsinore I look at
one of the biggest castles we have that
we consider a symbol of Denmark but well
people abroad will know this castle
Cornwall only when I say this is the
castle of Shakespeare's Hamlet then
everyone knows it all summers they have
the actors dressed in costumes from
Hamlet they play Hamlet everywhere and
say and and that castle anyways is
originally built by two Dutch architects
and I'm sure if you look around and lots
of things that you take pride in in
Britain and in culture the cultural
world is influenced inspired by or even
made by foreigners you know and you
can't in art for example take it out and
say well that was created a vacuum
national actually doesn't exist
everything is inference from somewhere
else and it would be so limiting if we
didn't allow this to flourish and you
know look at where the problems come
from which I really believe is the
deregulation over the last decades of
the financial world and we start
stopping that we look at what happened
with technology the influence in our
world that's also what makes people's
lives seem totally beyond control and
then from there you say okay that still
should not hamper the cultural exchange
and and we can make in Europe that
accommodates all of this for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you